welcome to tonight's program on the
michigan independent citizens
redistricting commission my name is john
miller i'm director of the dow
journalism program here at the college
and i'd like to welcome all of you who
are here with us on campus in placer
auditorium as well as those who are
watching on our live stream feed and
those who are listening
on radio free hillsdale 101.7
fm
for the next four hours
don't worry we only we only have the
room for uh for 90 minutes we're going
to talk about this uh redistricting
commission
and uh here at hillsdale college we are
one of the only schools in the country
that requires
students to take a course on the
constitution to graduate so we talk a
lot here about
elections and voting and representation
and they animate these questions animate
a lot of what we do around here so it
makes sense we would also take an
interest in this commission and what it
means for our state and we have a great
lineup of speakers tonight
i'm going to introduce them in in turn
starting with stephen markman and then
then our professors here uh kevin slack
and joe postel we'll start with uh
stephen markman who is uh perhaps the
best informed person on this
on this question in the state he is a uh
professor of constitutional law here at
hillsdale college he's taught here for
28 years he earned his undergraduate
degree from duke his jd from the
university of cincinnati in 1999 he was
appointed to the michigan supreme court
by governor john engler
and was subsequently re-elected to the
position he served on that court for 22
years including two as chief justice
prior to serving on the court he served
as an assistant u.s attorney general
under president ronald reagan and as a
u.s attorney under president george h.w
bush and on the michigan court of
appeals please give it up for stephen
markman
thank you john um
i appreciate any introduction of that
sort um
my last introduction when i was still on
the supreme court was
from a moderator who introduced me as
one of the finest judges that money
could buy
and
i think he was trying to say something
nice but i'm not sure if it came across
perfectly well
my wife who was uh with me on the
diocese was introduced as one of the
finest ladies to walk the streets and i
think she was similarly perplexed by the
introduction
so john thank you for the kind
introduction
i would like to talk
about the
the new
constitutional commission on
redistricting in michigan
it is going to be a commission that will
hopefully from the perspective of its
advocates serve as an example
across the union to other states
in the hope that they'll adopt some kind
of similar
commission some kind of similar proposal
to what we have in michigan
so the success or the lack thereof of
our commission in michigan i think is
going to be
an important
an important facet of whether
this is going to be emulated by other
states around the country
but to give you a little background late
last year
a report was issued by the school of
public policy at the university of
michigan
and presented to the new
uh independent citizens redistricting
commission
that was established by a vote of the
people in 2018 to become a new part of
our state's constitution
this year marks the first year of this
experiment in constructing
new electoral districts for congress and
our state legislature to serve for the
next decade as the foundation of
michigan's representative process
the commission is charged with the task
of constructing the boundaries for each
of these electoral districts replacing
in the process the legislature that had
been in charge of this task
since our statehood was first achieved
in 1837.
anyone reviewing the history and debate
of three years ago will see clearly that
the purpose of the new constitutional
amendment
is to address three principal concerns
first to curtail
so-called gerrymandering by which oddly
shaped and squiggly districts are
established to give one side or the
other electoral advantage
second to minimize the sheer
partisanship of the process
and third to avoid self-dealing
in which interested legislators
constructed districts that were most
advantageous to themselves and least
advantageous advantages to their future
competitors to say the least the new
commission is somewhat odd and certainly
a unique institution comprised of 13
members essentially drawn at random
picked out of a hat
more or less
four of whom are self-described
democrats
four self-described republicans
and
five self-described independents
this is an independent citizens
commission designed to bring a sense of
fresh air and energy to an increasingly
stale and antiquated
[Music]
electoral districting process
fair enough thus far although personally
i tend to prefer the kind of citizens
for such a critical public
responsibility
whom we the people you the people have
actually voted for
and for whom we can unvote if we dislike
their performance
four and this is what must be understood
most of all but seems not to be in light
of the scant attention given to the work
of the commission
these 13 haphazardly selected citizens
are presently engaged in constructing
the very building block of our system of
representative self-government the
fundamental units from which those who
are to represent us in our public
institutions will be selected
our members of congress and our
legislators in the state house and
senate will all be determined by votes
cast by people
joined and divided by these new
districts each of which will be more or
less inclined toward a particular
representative
a particular political party
in a particular
sense of public priorities as a direct
consequence of where these district
boundaries are placed
thus it's clearly not a trivial matter
for the process by which we select our
representatives is of course the
starting point for all else that follows
in our constitutional system one that's
given rise in my judgment to the freest
the most productive the most stable the
most innovative and inventive the most
genuinely compassionate and fair-minded
nation in the history of the world
an exceptional nation a chosen nation
now it so happens that the author of the
u of m report which was prepared in
consultant with the secretary of state
and thus becomes a quasi-official report
is understandably proud of his analysis
and is has asserted that it offers a new
theory of representation
those are his words although nothing
along these lines was heard during the
debate over the commission three years
ago
the emphasis then was voters not
politicians
a redistricting process shorn of
gerrymandering partisanship and
self-dealing
replacing in control politicians with
citizens
now instead the emphasis as i've
suggested something a little bit
different
a new theory of representation
and ultimately i've been persuaded that
the report's author is correct in this
assessment the report indeed presents a
new theory of representation
only that while it is new it is also in
my judgment a deeply misguided theory of
representation
and from this concern
hillsdale college an institution whose
scholars as you know
are unusually focused upon such hoary
concepts as democracy
representative institutions
self-government and public
accountability
as well as such anachronistic figures as
hamilton
madison and jefferson
hillsdale asked me earlier this year to
review the u of m report and to prepare
a responsive report on behalf of
hillsdale college
and i completed that test several months
ago and there are now competing analyses
of the new constitutional provision
and how it is likely to inform the work
of the equally new commission
these are essentially david and goliath
reports on the part of two outstanding
institutions of higher learning in our
state hillsdale college in the
university of michigan
although only the latter report has been
accorded what i've said is a apparently
official sanction
by the commission
now what is the essence of the dispute
on the part of hillsdale in the
university of michigan
at its core it has to do with the
fundamental nature of the representative
process
by what relationship should our public
officials be held accountable to the
people
in the present context this dispute is
straightforward and distilled as follows
what under the new constitutional
provision
is meant by the phrase community of
interest
which phrase describes the electoral
building blocks of our future
representative system of self-government
in michigan mightily important as we can
all agree i'm sure
hillsdale college
argues that the community of interest
should continue
as it has previously been in the law
to refer to genuine
geographic communities
based upon geographic boundaries in
particular those of our counties cities
and townships
hillsdale offers a number of specific
arguments on behalf of their
understanding
first that this is exactly
what has always and exclusively been
meant by the phrase communities of
interest in our redistricting law
specifically in the decisions of the
highest court of our state the michigan
supreme court the phrase in the context
of districting and redistricting has
only referred to
communities
real communities not metaphorical
communities
second actual districting practices in
michigan as well in almost every other
state of which i'm aware
have always been predicated as well upon
the boundaries of geographic communities
while of course the new constitutional
provision was meant to alter the law in
respects the public debate in 2018
was focused principally upon alterations
in terms of who was to be
the redistricting decision maker the
legislature or the commission
and the latter prevailed by a healthy
margin
and the express concerns with the status
quo as i've indicated we're focused
again upon gerrymandering partisanship
and self-dealing not the geographic
basis of electoral districts not
implementing a new theory of
representation
third hillsdale sees the virtue of
retaining geographic districts as
communities of interest is that every
citizen
every citizen is a part of such a
community
unlike the communities of interest
offered by u of m and the secretary of
state in which citizens will effectively
be pitted against each other in
contending for preferred community of
interest status
michigan's counties cities and townships
are genuine communities of interest to
which all citizens belong equally and in
which all share a common interest and
concern
and significantly for the process it is
a community of interest
whose definition
based upon geographic boundaries
requires no prolonged hearings or
debates by the commission
no expert consultations or statistical
assessments and no confirmation by a
vote of the 13 commissioners
if the consultants to the commission do
not understand this our citizens i
believe instinctively and certainly and
overwhelmingly understand that places
such as kent county the city of
marquette and bloomfield township
constitute genuine communities of
considerable interest for the people of
our state and do not require a seven to
six vote from the commission as
vindication for this
and finally as the hillsdale report
states
such communities geographic communities
of interest are where people reside
that where people sleep where they play
relax worship and mix with their
families friends and neighbors
they're where their children attend
schools
make and play with friends compete in
sports
participate in extracurricular
activities
and are educated and grow to maturity
they're where the people work shop dine
and participate in acts of charity
they're where their taxes are paid their
votes cast and library books borrowed
and returned and they're where their
police and firefighters and emergency
responders serve and protect
in short these communities of interest
from time immemorial have been truly
meaningful and definitive to every
michigander for they define what we call
home and they signify to the rest of the
world where we are from
by contrast
the u of m report defines communities in
of interest in a metaphorical fashion as
i've indicated in terms of special
interest
and identity
and affinity groups
in a manner in which the term has never
far before been defined in michigan law
or practice
this new theory of representation
this new theory of what should connect
the representative to those he or she
represents
would replace the individual citizen at
the center of the democratic process
with the interest group
it would substitute for the ideal of
equal citizenship
favored and disfavored voting blocs
it would enhance the role of race
ethnicity and religion as the
fundamental identifiers of the american
people
and it seeks to build a new electoral
and political foundation
upon the judgments and calculations
of experts rather those than those of
ordinary citizens it is in short a
theory of representation that is
grounded in ideology and identity
rather than in a commonly and equally
shared citizenship
rather than looking to the boundaries of
genesee county in the city of alpena and
the township of novi as the fundamental
building blocks of the representative
process the u of m report defines
these constituent elements much
differently
for sake of example and illustration
the report proposes as our new building
blocks and these are from its own words
communities of interest
predicated not upon geographic
boundaries but predicated upon
racial ethnic and religious identities
communities with common bonds
communities with a linkage to a set of
public policy issues that are affected
by legislation
communities with a shared vision of the
future
communities concerned about
environmental hazards
media markets
affinity groups among neighboring
jurisdictions
invisible communities of interest
like-minded nearby communities
communities with shared identities
communities with things things that bind
the community together
communities based upon determinations as
to how the community engages with the
political process
communities concerned about governmental
policies that are high priority
nearby areas whose inclusion would
strengthen and weaken representation for
the community of interest
public arts communities immigrant
communities enterprise zone communities
and special tax assessment based
communities
all calculated on the basis of metrics
that will reflect our clear measure of
compliance with a new amendment
communities of interest states u of m
can pick up the texture of bonds and
interest within a political jurisdiction
and they can capture the current
patterns of community life
whatever all that means
understand then that these in similar
considerations
are to replace
the single and predominant and historic
consideration
that has always been relied upon by
michigan
in constructing their electoral maps
actual geographic communities
and in listening to citizen testimony
offered to the commission over past
weeks and months this consideration
remains for most michigan citizens what
is most important
just not to the academic experts and
non-profit consultants for whom
literally the only consideration that
not cannot be considered in constructing
a community of interest the only
prohibited consideration the only
prohibited consideration
is the geographic community
can there be a single citizen within
within michigan
with an allegiance to his nbc media
market
or sense of attachment to the local
enterprise zone
or bond with his special assessment tax
district
are these the type of communities of
interest or electoral building blocks to
which a free and independent and
self-governing people would ever choose
to rest the future of their democracy
or to communicate as the defining
feature of their relationship
with their elected representatives
all of these factors are set forth in
the report that i've just listed with
virtually no explanation or analysis and
without reference to our state's
constitutional history or traditional
practices
or judicial law
much less any explanation as to what
requires a new theory of representation
at this particular moment in our history
and the vagueness and the unclarity
and the open-endedness
of most of these concepts things that
bind the community together
is apparently a virtue
from the perspective of the university
of michigan
for it allows the commission and its
experts and consultants
to do pretty much anything they wish
in reimagining our system of
constitutional government
it is already a commission largely and
uniquely devoid of checks and balances
and the breadth of new standards
proposed by the university of michigan
for the community of interest is further
empowering to this already
unprecedentedly
empowered commission
apparently the commission and its
experts will imbue these empty vessels
of language
with whatever
meanings and understandings it chooses
in reimagining the relationship between
the people and their representatives
and this bears no resemblance at all i
would respectfully suggest to the rule
of law to which the commission as with
all public entities must adhere
the rule of law is all about standards
the setting of rules criteria and
procedures that are defined in advance
of a substantive decision and applied in
an equal and consistent manner
standards lie at the core of the rule of
law in its decision-making yet there are
no serious standards
no intelligible or practical standards
underlying any of the university's
various word salads in giving meaning to
the community of interest
of course none of this complexity or
convolution or unchecked discretion
would be necessary if the report had
viewed the commission's responsibility
as simply organizing michigan's
political map in a fair-minded neutral
and non-partisan manner which is exactly
what the people voted for in 2018
but of course more obviously is required
if this map is to be reconfigured in
accord with some new theory of
representation
one that shares
no common understanding with the people
of michigan who ratified the measure
common understanding has always been the
standard by which we tried to give
meaning to constitutional provisions in
michigan
what was the common understanding of the
language of such provisions to the
people of our state
let me emphasize a couple further
observations made by the hillsdale
college report and i think it's
available to you outside here
first the report not only substitutes an
immense array of interest
identity and affinity considerations in
place of geographic ones in formulating
the community of interest
but it expressly asserts once again
that geographic considerations are the
only ones that cannot be taken into
account in formulating a community of
interest
that is the community of interest can
mean anything
in u of m's perspective from shared
media markets to linkages to public
policy issues affected by legislation to
affinity groups of limitless sorts
but the single thing it absolutely
cannot mean is what the term is always
before
signified communities defined
geographically
that is by real communities
communities to which most of the 10
million people of our state have a real
and bona fide allegiance
not the made-up and concocted
communities creatively devised by
experts who are determined to revive
redefine
the historic american concept of
political representation
secondly and perhaps significantly
the report
proposes communities of interest
predicated upon race ethnicity and
religion
almost without a doubt the most divisive
and polarizing possible
basis upon which our people should be
electorally arranged
the truly overarching question in this
regard
one that the michigan report neither
asks nor answers
did the people of michigan who ratified
this amendment in 2018
share a common understanding that by its
provisions in the first time in our
state's history
our constitution would impose an
affirmative obligation to take race
ethnicity and religion into account in
setting public policy
even though such an obligation in such
categories appear nowhere within the new
amendment
and did the people who ratif of michigan
who ratify this amendment
also share a common understanding that's
by its provisions the supreme law of our
state
would impose an affirmative obligation
to reconfigure electoral districts on
the basis of express calculations of
race ethnicity and religion
and did the people of michigan who
ratify this amendment
share a common understanding that's by
its provisions
there would be a partial nullification
and undermining of the precepts of
article 1 section 2 of that constitution
that no people shall be denied the equal
protection of the laws
nor shall any person being
denied the enjoyment of his civil or
political rights
to be discriminated against in the
exercise
on the basis of race religion race color
or national origin
and did the people of michigan who
ratified the amendment share a common
concern
or common understanding that by its
provisions
at the same time we were according
advantage to some racial ethnic and
religious groups we would necessarily
be imposing disadvantage upon other
racial ethnic and religious groups in
the zero-sum world of electoral
redistricting
and finally did the people of michigan
who ratified the amendment share a
common understanding that by its
provisions they would also be acting in
a contrary manner with the precepts of
article 1 section 26 of our constitution
a constitutional initiative enacted in
2006
that forbade the state
including expressly and interestingly
the university of michigan
from discriminating against or granting
preferential treatment to any individual
or group on the basis of race
sex color ethnicity or national origin
in the context of a broad number of
public policy areas
and third it should be clearly
recognized that if the commission
eventually adopts the recommendations of
the university of michigan report and
rejects those of hillsdale
little will be left of its potential
legacy of reform
there will not be an end to the things
that prompted the constitutional
amendment under the rubric of voters not
politicians
rather each of the deficiencies in the
process that led to the reforms
may be perpetrated or even worsened but
this time under the color and protection
of camouflage
consider first how much of the state
media such as the detroit free press
hailed the new commission
process as an end to gerrymandering
certainly there have been such abuses on
the part of both republicans and
democrats over the years were each have
been in control of the legislature and
thus the redistricting process but the
principal deterrent to the worst abuses
have been exactly the rules that long
guided the redistricting process in
particular the obligation of the map
makers to respect geographic boundaries
the so-called apoll standards
named after the state election director
who crafted the present standards 40
years ago required that wherever
possible district boundaries must be
drawn to contain only whole counties and
that any crossing of county lines be
minimized in number
and that even when county lines needed
to be divided as few city and township
lines as possible should be shifted or
divided
the result was election districts that
were largely and overwhelmingly
regularly shaped
in which what were then understood to be
communities of interest
places in which people actually lived
were maintained intact
consider however how communities of
interest will be constructed where the
dispositive considerations are identity
categories special interest groups and
cross-jurisdictional affinities and
shared interests especially we're guided
by a report that assumes that asserts
that geographic communities can't be
considered as communities of interest
the result will be far more districts
that unnecessarily
snake and squiggle and contort across
the map in search of more people to
include in districts and more people to
exclude from the newly re-oriented
communities of interest
consider second the expectation that the
commission will curtail partisan
decision-making
while the removal of the process from
the control of the legislature obviously
moves in that direction it does not move
very far when you take into account that
many of the racial ethnic and religious
and special interest and affinity and
shared interests and legislation
considerations that are urged by u of m
can easily be employed to allow
equivalent
partisan and political advantages to be
made but surreptitiously and less
obviously
those for example who view the
commission as having a legal mandate to
optimize the votes of racial ethnic and
religious groups or to merge affinity
groups across jurisdictions
who favor or disfavor particular
legislation or to enhance the influence
of communities with the shared vision of
the future
whatever that's
understood to signify
not only misunderstand the commands of
the law and constitution but are
effectively engaged in partisan
calculations every bit as much as the
most partisan legislature but again
undercover
and finally consider the expectations
that the commission will end
self-dealing by legislators
certainly by transferring redistricting
responsibilities
upon the commission
there'll be some gain in removing the
legislators from that process
but what about the self-dealing
u of m urges upon the commission
according to the university there's
virtually no limit as to what might
serve as a community of interest except
that it cannot be what everyone views a
real community of interest to be
therefore there are literally an
unlimited number of competing
aggregations of people in our state who
can be treated as communities of
interest to be accorded advantage by the
commission
while all other aggregations of people
will enjoy no such thumbs on the scales
justice and fair treatment
and as a result
and because there are no intelligible
standards as a result
racial ethnic
and religious groups will be treated as
communities of interest to be favored in
the political process and some will be
treated as being disfavored in the
process and there'll be no standards for
determining why some are treated in one
way and some are treated in the other
way and which affinity groups deserve
designation
and which don't deserve designation
again will be subject to standardless
decisions there are simply no rules in
the law for these and countless similar
decisions the commission will confront
to be sure they'll no longer be
self-dealing by the state senator
congressman and that is all to the good
in my view but instead there will be
newfound opportunities for the
commissioners themselves to exercise
their broadened discretion on base of
basis of identity on behalf of identity
groups special interests and affinity
categories to which they either belong
or share a personal preference
the commission has the opportunity
either to separate or to unite
to separate our peoples members of
interest groups and identity categories
or to unite them as independent citizens
entitled to an equal place in the
electoral process
furthermore the commission is positioned
to influence similar amendments
considered by other states which are now
assessing the michigan example hillsdale
college presumes that in ratifying the
present amendment the people were doing
exactly what was heralded at the time
they were establishing a redistricting
process at whose core would be voters
not politicians and not reimagining
their democracy or experimenting with
new theories of representation thank you
[Applause]
it occurs to me that my community of
interest
is the broadcast zone of fox sports
detroit
so thank you for those clarifying
remarks uh justice markman next up is
kevin slack he's a professor
associate professor of politics here at
hillsdale college and kevin you have a
bunch of degrees i didn't realize he has
an undergraduate degree in history from
indiana university and m.a in political
science from
uc davis and emman political theory from
the university of dallas's phd in
politics from the university of dallas
so you're a student for a long time but
we decided to let him teach here at
hillsdale college he teaches
constitution public policy political
philosophy he's also the author of a
book called benjamin franklin natural
right and the art of virtue give it up
for kevin slack
[Applause]
in 2018 michigan voters approved a
ballot referendum to transfer the duty
of redistricting from the legislature to
a citizens independent redistricting
commission
because seeing gerrymandered districts
they wanted to end absurdly drawn
partisan boundaries that protected
incumbents particularly republicans
and many republican voters supported
this from a sense of fairness
gerrymandered district's crack packers
stack district populations
dividing traditional geographic
communities for reasons of partisanship
and interest
section 13 c of the amendment states
quote districts shall reflect the
state's diverse population and
communities of interest and quote in
interpreting what communities of
interest are the commission should
itself be cautious to avoid the charge
of partisanship
to do so it should look to what the
voters intended by the phrase as well as
legal precedent
they should ignore the university of
michigan's report which seeks to subvert
both
the um report which has been endorsed by
the secretary of state places its own
reinterpretation of communities of
interest as one of its quote highest
priorities for the upcoming
redistricting
it also admits that while legal
community of interest has have existed
for decades in michigan their own
interpretation of it is new
it departs from long-standing precedent
the report seeks to redefine cois so
that it can influence the redis
redistricting commission to make
decisions unauthorized by either the
amendment or legal precedent the report
reads quote information on michigan's
population its local political
jurisdictions and voting patterns are
relatively easy to compile and make
available to the icrc
the same is not true for communities of
interest there are there is no
comprehensive definition of a coi beyond
the words in the constitution and as a
result there is no compilation of
information about the state's cois end
quote
thus instead of relying on michigander's
own idea of fairness the um report
provides a list of categories of cois
compiled by supposed academic experts to
direct the redistricting commission on
how to proceed
the first problem with the um's report
the um report's definition of cois is
that instead of traditional geographic
communities what michiganders generally
seem to report as their own communities
of interest
anything could be interpreted as a
community of interest thus the very ills
of gerrymandering michigan voters wanted
to avoid will in the long term be
exacerbated by the report's
reinterpretation
secondly the um reinterpretation of
communities of interest in the amendment
brings serious legal concerns
it violates long-standing precedent that
has understood districts to be
geographic communities aligned with
counties cities and townships
the michigan state supreme court has
determined quote the basic building
blocks of the apportionment rules are
the counties the senate and the house
are to be organized into contiguous
single member districts drawn on county
lines end quote
moreover it upholds quote requirements
that the county city and township lines
be observed in redistricting and
apportionment and that election
districts be compact
so long as they don't violate federal
constitutional requirements and there's
good sense in this
the court has argued that quote the
historical practice of following county
lines has always been simply a device
for controlling gerrymandering
facilitating elections and preserving
communities of interest end quote
nothing in the amendment establishing
the redistricting commission overturns
that precedent
again communities of interest only
restates the common sense geographic
boundaries that have long represented
michigan's diverse communities
because cois are not defined the way
that the um report interprets the
redistricting commission must look first
legal precedent the second legal concern
is that the um report's own
interpretation of cois includes no
limiting principle for a court's
interpretation
according to the report quote a
community of interest is a group of
individuals who share common bonds
economic ethnic cultural et cetera but
what may communities of interest not
include
the um report itself states
quote the concept of a coi is subjective
and it is subjective and in no state is
it well defined end quote
thus the purpose for injecting this
artificial confusion is to replace the
traditional geographic communities
where the supreme court has determined
that county lines are the quote building
blocks of districts the um report posits
that its own new list of communities are
to be the quote building blocks of the
new districts
yet the old building blocks were the
communities themselves which represented
the interests of those in their
geographic boundaries
now um wants to divide those districts
by race ethnicity and religion and unify
them with pockets of other cois
while the while the um report bills its
building blocks as quote historical
communities they explicitly appeal to
the most divisive identities including
quote racial communities immigrant
communities and language communities
this is the new theory of representation
that it forwards again the um
interpretation of communities of
interest if adopted by the redistricting
commission would set a dangerous
precedent
a state constitutional mandate for
racial gerrymandering
but that language was never included in
the ballot referendum because
michiganders would never have voted yes
to racial gerrymandering arguably the
worst kind what the voters wanted was
normalization of district lines and an
end to the gerrymandering that corrupted
the vital principle of representation
again if the redistricting commission
accepts the um reinterpretation of
communities of interest it is
implementing a racial interpretation
that michigan voters did not approve
finally there's a gulf between the
language of the amendment which says
that cois do not include relationships
with political parties and the reality
that all redistricting has partisan
interests and outcomes michigan voters
are not naive they know that
redistricting is fraught with
partisanship
but they wanted redistricting to be less
partisan
yet reportedly two of the five so-called
independent commissioners have strong
ties to the democrat party or liberal
causes one so-called independent
supported bernie sanders
commissioners are randomly selected by
the secretary of state's office which is
run by democrat jocelyn benson
not only should the commissioners
attempt to temper these interests they
should acknowledge that its decisions
will establish precedent for the rest of
the country
secretary benson herself voiced her
hopes that michigan set a national
precedent and we are already seeing cois
being presented as a central priority
for redistricting at the federal level
in both the house and in the senate
the goal of the um report is to
represent michiganders not as
individuals or members of a community
but as tokens of identity politics its
new interpretation of communities of
interest focuses on dividing americans
by mutually exclusive identities of race
and ethnicity the commission members
must ask if more political division is
really what michigan and the country
needs thank you
[Applause]
thanks kevin next up is joe postel who
is an associate professor of politics
here at hillsdale college he earned his
undergraduate degree in history
philosophy and political science from
ashland university and his m.a and phd
in politics from the university of
dallas he's written a book called
bureaucracy in america the
administrative state's challenge to
constitutional democracy he's the
co-author or co-editor of several other
volumes he teaches here at hillsdale
college on the constitution political
parties and elections before coming to
hillsdale he was an associate professor
of polit political science at the
university of colorado at colorado
springs give it up for joe postel
[Applause]
thank you thank you all for being here
and uh thank you to the college for
giving me the opportunity to speak
tonight thanks um also especially to
justice markman for his work and his
leadership on this
critical issue my role here tonight is
to supplement what's already been said
and so i'll be brief
redistricting battles are these ever
recurring partisan
conflicts that tend to arouse public
passions in to an inordinate degree
it's easy in the midst of these battles
to mistakenly focus on short-term and
partisan calculations rather than
long-term and principled considerations
so what i want to do in a short amount
of time is to just take a step back
and think about why geography matters in
determining representation in the first
place in this country
and what good it does us to consider
geography and how we represent voters
ultimately i think our constitutional
system rests fundamentally on the idea
of geographic districts and we risk
jeopardizing that system if we start to
think about communities of interest as
separate from geography
as justice markman has noted
the university of michigan report boasts
that it is advocating for a new theory
of representation
and that that new theory of
representation is contained in this
phrase that's been discussed already
the communities of interest
if this is the case again it's not known
what this phrase will mean
practically speaking but if this is the
case that we are embracing a new theory
of representation before embarking on
such a journey we ought to understand
the benefits associated with the
constitutional theory of representation
and why the constitution's framers
embraced it
that theory of representation can be
summarized as follows in the first place
representation is supposed to in the
famous words of federalist number 10
refine and enlarge the public views
rather than purely reflect the public
will
in this theory our elected
representatives should not blindly
follow the will of the public but should
be capable of resisting public opinion
when it would be dangerous to the
public's long-term interests to blindly
follow it
this new theory of representation as far
as i can tell
sees representation not as a way of
refining the public's views but a
mechanism for reflecting their
characteristics it's a mirror theory of
representation rather than a refining
theory
the second purpose of representation
again most notably advanced in james
madison's famous federalist number 10
is to promote a pluralism or a diversity
of interests through an extended
republic
in that famous essay as is well known
madison declared that the size of the
republic would
be a source of control on the power of
factions
while factions might be able to win a
majority over a small territory
in a large republic each faction is
counteracted by the other factions that
prevail in other parts of the country
now although this was not fully
understood by madison himself when he
wrote federalist number ten the basic
idea was implicit representation should
be by geography to reflect the pluralism
of interests that are rooted in
geography
in other words madison envisioned
representation as being
or as reflecting a community of
interests
spread across a large republic rather
than one single national and homogenous
people
specific representatives coming from
specific geographically grounded
districts
reflecting the local interests and the
local communities that they were
supposed to serve would be advocates of
those interests
so paradoxically the plan was to
increase the number of interests and the
conflicts among those interests
in order to reduce conflict as a whole
so this system would encourage
deliberation it would encourage
bargaining
and compromise
because all of these distinct
communities represented by distinct
representatives would have to build
majority coalitions capable of governing
in summary the theory of representation
for the founders was twofold
representatives should be able to rise
above the will of their constituents
when that will was contrary to the
public good
and they should be rooted geographically
in
those communities of interest so that
they could advance those geographic
interests throughout the extended
republic
now this view of representation which
values the sanctity of geographic
communities has not fared well in an age
of modern technology and innovation
and it's also been damaged significantly
by government policies that have
weakened local representation
as i think is well known by all of us
communities themselves have been eroded
and weakened by
developments rooted in modern technology
and innovation not so long ago tip
o'neill famously quipped that all
politics is local
no sensible observer of american
politics today would agree
all politics has become national
communities have lost their unique
identities
transportation brings people from
different communities closer together
but it weakens attachments within
communities social media connects us to
people across the country and causes
friction between neighbors of differing
views
these technological changes which have
weakened geographic identities in
geographic communities have been
exacerbated by reforms such as campaign
finance laws that encourage outside
influence in local elections more money
is spent by outside contributors than by
citizens who are voting in these
elections
the effects of these disruptions are
before our eyes on a daily basis they're
all around us americans are increasingly
divided along national partisan lines
rather than regional geographic
interests
local interests exert comparatively
little influence over elections these
days
which tend to reflect national
ideological commitments instead of
geographic communities of interest
members of congress increasingly cater
to national groups and outside funders
rather than listening to community
leaders
and local citizens and advancing those
interests
these political changes have revamped
our political system over the last 30
years
instead of directing our attention to
congress with its messy pluralism and
multiplicity of interests
people increasingly think of the
president as the sole national
representative
people are more attached to their
national party than their local
community this means that political
conflict centers around presidential
elections and is increasingly divisive
and personalized
any approach to drawing districts that
represents community of interest
communities of interest without rooting
those communities in well communities
almost inevitably will exacerbate these
trends
congress will become increasingly
irrelevant as geographic communities
lose their integrity and autonomy
politics will become increasingly
nationalized polarized and centered on
the bare majority represented by the
occupant of the white house
congress will go further down the path
that it is already on a mere rubber
stamp for the president's prerogatives
when the same party controls both
branches or a focal point of national
resistance against the president's
agenda in a state of divided government
in either scenario actual geographic
communities will be washed over by
national politics and polarization
this is certainly not the future that
our founders had in mind when they
constructed the constitutional theory of
representation nor is it the future that
most americans want and has already been
as has already been indicated it's not
the future that michiganders voted for
americans are increasingly disillusioned
with national politics distrustful of
the national government and alienated
from their fellow residents and towns
across america
our founders knew that conflict in an
extended republic would be inevitable
they also believed that conflict could
be advantageous by protecting us from
groupthink from majority tyranny and
from faction
but the system they designed was not
intended to nationalize politics nor to
erode our sense of place in community
communities of interest should be
represented
that's how people have always been
represented in american politics but
communities of interest have to be
rooted in communities grounded in
geographic places
the mere act of drawing congressional
district lines cannot reverse these
larger trends that have plagued american
politics over the past generation for
better and for worse americans no longer
identify as strongly with their
geographic communities of interest
however this is not an argument for
abandoning the traditional understanding
of communities of interest but an
argument for reinforcing and supporting
that traditional understanding
if we're going to keep governing
ourselves peacefully resolving our
differences through bargaining and
compromise
accelerating these trends pushing us
further into a nationalized partisan and
polarized people won't make it any
easier
instead the strength of our union
depends in large part on preserving
geographic communities of interest as
the basis for our representative system
abandoning geography as a central
feature in defining communities of
interest will only accelerate the
alarming pace with which americans are
dividing and denouncing each other
sending members of congress who speak
for the communities they're supposed to
serve
rather than the national ideological
agendas of interest groups
will facilitate bargaining and mutual
accommodation that will enable all of
these interests to live together
harmoniously
hopefully we can remember these lessons
as we go about this ever-recurring task
of drawing districts and we can aim to
preserve geographic communities rather
than weaken them further thank you
[Applause]
thank you joe
and we're now able to take some of your
questions i think do we have a
microphone
working the room yes we do um uh
uh so if you have questions just just uh
raise your hand and we'll bring the mic
to you i'm going to start
with a question
for
the whole panel
and or or maybe one of you can answer it
which is a question about timeline
we're in october of 2021
a year from now we're going to be in the
thick of
a congressional midterm election
election for representatives here in
michigan also governor
and more
this commission hasn't drawn its lines
yet is there a moment by which it must
draw them when will we know
what is it doing to consider the
michigan report the university of
michigan report the hillsdale report and
so on uh what what do we foresee over
the next few months
well there is a deadline the
legislation um required the commission
to
circulate the maps that it prepared
several by several weeks ago
they missed that deadline
it's still not been completed the
process is supposed to be completed by
the end of the year at which point the
new districts would
take effect in the law and they would
control the elections in 2022
but we seem a long way from that and
you know one wonders whether there are
any possible sanctions or how that
situation is going to be dealt with but
i don't know what's happening right now
in terms of the day-to-day deliberations
of the commission or when we're likely
to see the maps that
should have been here several weeks ago
who would like to stump our panel was a
tough question we have one over here it
looks like
hi thank you all for coming out tonight
so i kind of just wanted to ask for a
sec considering that it's the
politicians and the major political
figures who benefit the most
from you know redistricting even under
this independent commission and that
they have a lot of say in you know
promoting or you know rallying the
people against certain constitutional
amendments or movements is there any
practical benefit that you know we in
this argument in a return to uh
redistricting based upon geographic
boundaries are there any practical
benefits that we can sell to our
political leaders and figures to get
them on our side of this argument as
otherwise i would just probably foresee
them all rallying their strength and
their political capital against the
initiative and using the institutions to
ultimately defeat it
sure
this is maybe less a tangible benefit
but i think
this sort of the thrust of my remarks
was that
we have an increasingly dysfunctional
national political environment
most people are really dissatisfied with
that environment and this will
basically accelerate all of the trends
that have produced that environment so
if you want
a politics that looks different from the
kind of politics we have today
this approach is actually going to give
you more of the same rather than
something different so that's less a
tangible benefit to offer but more
maybe a return to a more functional
political system which i do think there
is a lot of desire there's a significant
desire for that and i think that desire
crosses a lot of partisan
lines so that would be what i would
offer
to people who are really interested in
what our argument would offer
i mean i would
just add to that and say there's
something be said for a sense of justice
and i think that's why so many people
voted in favor of the amendment
when you look at gerrymandering i think
people have just an innate sense that
there's something not fair about this
and so you can find people of both
parties
who can come together and say what we
want are more normalized
contiguous and compact districts
and so that's something where if you
have competitive districts um that
people will think it's fair even if they
don't appreciate the outcome of the
election
thank you for your addresses tonight my
mind is very basic since this is a
commission
how is it held accountable to the voters
well
the commission is not accountable in
traditional ways to the voters at all
and was intended not to be accountable
in traditional ways
again
these individuals who are performing an
extraordinarily important function
within our governmental system
have never been subject to a vote not
one of them to the best of my knowledge
has secured a single
vote from among the 10 million people of
our state
they can't be removed to the best of my
knowledge from office
they are going to be in control of this
process for 10 years
for all i know and i believe they are
decent individuals engaged citizens of
the state of michigan
they're trying to do
a public service they're trying to do
what they presume to be their duty
but normally the way that we select
individuals for functions
this extraordinarily important for our
system is to have
the
the people we the people
having some opportunity to communicate
their thoughts about what kind of people
should be representing them in this
process
and that is the great uh missing element
of this process these individuals were
literally chosen at random i've never
heard of a selection process that was so
disengaged from any effort to try to
give the people a responsible voice in
their exercise of self-government
it's it's a remarkable institution and i
don't cast any aspersion upon the 13
members of the commission
again i think they're trying to do what
they think is right but the fact is we
don't have any selection process other
than somebody reaching deep into a hat
and picking out names at random
and
it's just not the way that this kind of
decision making ought to be done
but in fairness it's the way that this
commission was structured from the very
beginning
the people of the state who voted on
this and supported the amendment in 2018
did presumably have an opportunity to
read the language
and if they did they didn't seem to be
too hot and bothered by the procedures
that we created in this amendment
so um how do you hold them accountable
uh
at this point all you can do is use the
bully pulpit in various ways and
hillsdale to its great credit not to
mine but to hillsdale's credit they were
the one who decided that they wanted to
participate in this process
they have decided to use the bully
pulpit and that in part is what we're
doing here this evening and um how much
impact it's had i don't know it's a
a lot of this is what i've described as
kind of inside the beltway issues and
don't immediately capture the interest
of
ordinary citizens within our state but
when you have an initiative process as
we do in the state of michigan by which
constitutional
provisions can be placed directly on the
ballot by a vote of the people
without the involvement of the
legislature and without the deliberation
of that process the people do have an
obligation
people in the end get the government
they deserve and they do have the
obligation to read the amendment and to
understand from their own perspective
what the strengths and weaknesses of
those amendments are i presume they did
that in this case before voting in favor
of the amendment but
you have to
you have to trust the people to do the
right thing in this kind of direct
representative process of constitutional
initiatives
another question
you know back back there
thank you does the federal constitution
say anything about
who is to do the reapportioning
does it reference that that the state
legislatures are to do that
what does the constitution say about who
does reapportioning in the states
i bet one of these professors knows
i mean the authority rests with the
state legislature if you're looking for
you know article and clause i'm sorry i
can't provide that for you right now
well i've been told
that the federal constitution references
the fact that the state legislatures are
to reapportion so if that's true if
that's true
then my question becomes
all these independent commissions
whether in michigan or in iowa or
wherever
if the state legislatures did not
grant their
authority
to these commissions
are they even constitutional
under the federal constitution
i don't recall if it specifies which
part of the states
uh
are supposed to take on the
responsibility of reapportionment i'm
not i don't recall if it necessitates
the state legislatures doing that or
whether it just specifies that the
states do that so that would be one
question to
look into
i don't believe the federal constitution
is implicated here i think the federal
constitution focuses upon states making
these decisions presumably on whatever
basis they choose to make them
in our state as with virtually every
other state
that process has always involved state
legislatures
several years ago arizona and then the
state of california enacted commissions
not necessarily um
altogether similar to our commission but
that was done
and
i don't know that we would want the
federal constitution
to be interfering with whatever
processes we the people of michigan
selected to
implement and facilitate our own
redistricting processes and if the
people of michigan want to do that by
a commission placed in the constitution
or they want to continue to allow the
state legislature
to make these decisions it seems to me
that
nothing in those decisions implicates uh
the more general commands of the federal
constitution
more questions we got someone right down
in front here
i would like to thank the panel of
course for all their great work tonight
i've enjoyed it very much my question
involves
kind of two parts but they're really
related
how are they getting the information for
making these districts is it census data
are they interviewing people are is it
just the feelings of the committee and
then the legislature
as said and then secondarily how they
deal with influxes of new citizens and
god forbid ohioans if they were to go
into certain
districts
if i was in say a dearborn muslim
district and i moved there
and it was districted on the fact that i
was or that they were muslim excuse me
how would i be treated would would the
district's thing reflect me because when
you move you have to change geography
i don't become muslim or middle eastern
because i move somewhere else so how are
they addressing these problems in the
committee and then
if there are problems at all and what
are they trying to find for the
information
to actually district
i mean from people from people that i've
talked to about this uh when it comes to
particularly the southern counties
there's not much knowledge at all so
imagine opening up your telephone book
and saying oh here's the chamber of
commerce or here's a particular church
i think one of the um
oh disingenuous parts of the report is
the listing of say religion
and so you might find say the
recognition of an anglican church in a
county similar but is that really going
to be used for the composition of a
district no so i think really what's
going on here is the attempt to
use this
right this phrase communities of
interest so that you could
come up with anything as the nuts and
bolts for gerrymander
we have a question
back here
this is uh former state representative
eric lloyd heyzer thank you and i
thank thanks the panel um spot on and
and um
communities of interest obviously the
big
um
functional problem with this with this
proposal
um
there's another phrase that's that's
i in my view equally problematic i'd
like to know if you have
know about whether it's it at work
uh in our michigan
commission or not and that is
um the efficiency gap the so-called
notion that any votes over a
51-49 split are wasted and so the goal
is to have every district to be as close
to 50 50 as possible i think it's a
horrible idea because
of what you just the student just said
about moving and people want to
self-select and be around people like
themselves
but i don't know if the michigan
commission is playing around with this
term or if this term is gaining traction
in michigan or in the other states that
you've studied this notion of an
efficiency gap
thank you
yeah i am be happy to i've been thinking
about this question quite a bit
i think ultimately the long-term goal of
people who are behind these efforts
is to fundamentally attack the way in
which
representation works in this country
and the way it's described is that we
have a sort of first-past-the-post
system in which there's one member from
a district whoever gets the most votes
in that district wins all of the
representation so if you win 51 to 49
you get 100 of the representation and
the 49 percent get zero
now that has
from the point of view of people who i
think are behind these efforts the
possibility of distorting outcomes to
where you can win say one party could
win more votes statewide than the other
party but not win more of the districts
than the other party
and so the goal to get around this
problem is either you eliminate or
abolish districts completely which is
obviously a difficult thing to
accomplish
or
you close the efficiency gap and you do
that in two ways right one is
you get rid of all the wasted votes that
come from winning a district 60 40 when
you only needed to win at 40 50 51 to 49
and then you reallocate those votes to
places where you might actually be able
to win if you put those votes over there
um
i take this then to be not really about
and i think that this is consistent with
a lot of the things that have been said
i take these efforts not to really be
about
trying to represent communities of
interest
but more about how to win
national
you know entrenched
partisan policy
victories
um
and
that i think as i've you know reiterated
here i think that could be very damaging
for our pop national politics especially
given the trajectory that we're on so
um i think you're right to highlight
that issue as something that needs more
attention
a question right in the middle here
going to make it as hard as possible for
these uh
folks with the mics
thank you very much
i understand this commission was drawn
up by ballot initiative and if you could
just particularly for justice markman if
you could explain what that is what
they're used for typically
and whether or not a ballot initiative
would be effective in this case
well the commission was adopted by a
constitutional initiative which allowed
the people to introduce a constitutional
amendment
vote on that amendment and ratify it
which they did
and the proposition thereby becomes a
part of the constitution
of course you could i don't see anything
in the constitution that would prohibit
a counter initiative if that's what
you're saying if i'm understanding you
correctly
i don't think that's likely to happen we
don't have much of a history of
counter initiatives in the way that we
do have the 18th and 21st amendments to
the united states comp
constitution having to do with
prohibition which pretty much follow
that kind of sequence the 21st amendment
basically undoing the 18th amendment and
cancelling out
prohibition
but i i do think
we're not going to see any any
rectifying
or
remedying a constitutional proposal
until the people really understand some
aspects of the current amendment a
little bit better than they perhaps do
right now
i think if the average person in the
state of michigan
were to read the university of michigan
report or read the critique in the
hillsdale report of the michigan report
they would really uh
gasp at the
incongruity
of the proposals of the university of
michigan with their own perception of
what it was that they were voting for in
2018
i think would be extraordinarily
interesting if there was some kind of
poll
to uh get some sense of how the people
perceive the kinds of things that the
university of michigan is proposing in
facilitating their new theory of
representation
i really think that
you you can walk across the streets of
any community in this country in this
state
you can describe to them what the
universe university of michigan is
proposing and i think there will be
gasps and disbelief that somehow they
have contributed to placing in the
constitution
such a utter transformation of our
constitutional system
not only the explicit consideration of
race and ethnicity and religion
but the
the
total
derogation
of
everything that's traditionally guided
this this
this practice now i don't know exactly
to what extent the commission
is going to adopt or concur with the
recommendations of the university of
michigan
but the fact that there is the
involvement of the secretary of state in
that process really does confer upon its
recommendations
uh an aura of semi-legitimacy
and that's why so many of us are
assuming that the commission will at
least give more than ordinary deference
and respect to the proposals of u of m
as opposed to the proposals that say
hillsdale has and we do have specific
proposals
and if any of you have our report and i
know it's available here i would urge
you perhaps to start with the proposals
and recommendations that we make at the
end of the report because they summarize
pretty well what the concerns are of
hillsdale with a larger proposition
under consideration here
another question we got one right down
in front here
thank you to the panelists i have two
questions uh if i may um the first
question i the a lot of the work that
the i think all of the work that the
commission is doing um is public record
and a lot of it is available online on
their website so i was looking at some
of the proposed maps that they're
considering and i saw one map where a
sliver of hillsdale county was kind of
sliced off and
attached to some neighborhoods in
detroit i think i saw another map where
parts of hillsdale were matched up with
lansing and ann arbor and i just i can't
fathom how one representative can
represent
uh neighborhoods in
both hillsdale county and detroit or
both hillsdale and ann arbor
so to me this just looks like
gerrymandering under another name um so
my first question is i'm just wondering
if the word independent is a misnomer um
uh is old-fashioned gerrymandering more
honest i know i know we kind of we kind
of squeal and cringe at the the way
gerrymandering has been used in recent
recent decades but isn't old-fashioned
gerrymandering more honest um and what
what advice would you give to these
quote-unquote independent commissioners
um to to make sure their work is as
independent as possible um the second
question and dr brustell was starting to
get into this a little bit towards the
end of his comments um does does what
what's happening here in michigan and
what could possibly happen across the
nation
i know the for the people act is kind of
stalled in congress but
if it were enacted it would require
independent independent commissions like
this one in michigan in every state in
the country
does this constitute regime change uh dr
bostel was getting into you know what
republicanism means what representation
means uh for the the framers of the
constitution this sounds wholly
different um is is this a new regime
altogether what would the country look
like what what would our politics look
like uh where this should be adopted on
a mass scale thank you
yeah so i mean i think
the first question
um
you know
about gerrymandering i mean i think
there are a lot of
myths about gerrymandering and its
effect on american politics
most people think that polarization and
gerrymandering are somehow connected or
that gerrymandering is driving a lot of
what's happening in our politics today
the better explanation for what's
happening in our politics is that we are
sorting ourselves into like-minded
communities so
you would have to in order to create
sort of moderate
representatives you would have to
gerrymander districts in order to put
people who think differently back
together given the ways in which people
have moved into places where people
think like them so
and it does lead to the second question
right what would our national politics
look when we go down this path i think
we've already seen it i think we're
catching glimpses of it already
it's every four years this is the most
important election of your lifetime
um scorched earth battles
to win 51 to 49
majorities for one office it gets to
make all of the decisions bare
majoritarianism that kind of thing so
that isn't a recipe for compromise and
deliberation and mutual accommodation
and so that's why i think it's really
important to pause at a juncture like
this and think about the future we want
to have politically
we have time for one more question
and this
young man here will ask it
uh thank you for each of your talks and
i thought they were very enlightening
um right now i'm taking american
political thought and we spent the past
three weeks talking about the
anti-federalists and their views on
representation and i'm just curious on
how this new
vision of representation would compare
to traditional anti-federalist
thought i'm sorry i couldn't clearly
hear that final that final presentation
of the question could you just repeat
that please i'm just curious on how this
new vision of representation would
compare to anti-federalist visions of
representation
i mean i would say succinctly when i
think of the federal anti-federalist i
think of
small republicanism
right citizen participation stress on
virtue when i think about this form of
representation
it really emerges in the i mean you
always have interest groups that play an
important role in american history but
this form of representation really
emerges the 1960s
gene kirkpatrick who was a democrat
herself in 1974 talked about this new
form of representation that you find in
the democrat party as part of the
mcgovern commission 1972
where there are de facto racial quotas
that will be included in representation
among the delegates
the basic point was is in order to
overthrow that kind of mid-century
liberal
color-blind view which they viewed as
dishonest
because america was systemically racist
what you needed to do was to represent
explicitly certain gender and race
groups
um and you call those the new states if
you will right so this is the way we
ought to understand the american
electorate i think anti-federalists they
have a very different view of
republicanism
and
despite their differences with the
federalists on how large the regime
would be republicanism really was the
common thread that ran through
both sides of that disagreement
and so republicanism not just as a kind
of forum but literally as a kind of soul
where people participated very
intimately in local politics
fast forward to today and what do we
have we literally have the democrat
candidates talking about doing away with
the electoral college and we have
republicans in michigan who are voting
for michigan to allocate its electors
based on the popular vote so in other
words to make michigan irrelevant in
national politics
that has nothing in common with
republicanism at all
yeah i i wanted to
just say one thing before we ended our
evening together here
and that is i think that
some of the people who have been most
poorly
treated by this process are the members
of the commission themselves
remember again these are citizens
who've been drawn randomly and placed on
a commission
they knew they were signing up for an
important responsibility a critical role
they were aware of that
but i don't think they were aware
that their job was going to go beyond
establishing regularly shaped districts
and diminishing partisanship and doing
their best doing their level best to
create
honest and fairly put together districts
in that their role would be expanded
beyond that
to assessing the future visions of
communities across the state of michigan
in trying to weigh those visions that
were best and that ought to be rewarded
with community of interest status
assessing legislative policies that do
or don't bind us together and again
trying to
reward those communities and those group
affinity groups and special interests
that favor certain policies i just don't
think these were the kinds of things
that most of these commission members
really expected they were signing up for
i don't know that they feel they have
any particular sense beyond any other
citizen of what are high priority public
policies and how do we promote those
high priority public policies by
squiggling around districts and getting
uh hundreds or thousands of people who
all share a common interest in those
high priority policies and when i say
squiggle around in squiggly districts of
course that's a legal term that you may
not be aware of but it describes the
kind of gerrymandering that we're
talking about here but i don't think
that these commissioners really had any
sense that they were signing up
to be our philosopher kings
the purveyors of our new theory of
representation
i just think that they're probably as
shocked by what they're seeing in some
of these proposals as i and perhaps some
of you are
so i think we have to understand that
the culprit here are not the members of
the commission
it's the experts and the for-profit
academicians and
the individuals who really do have an
ideological acts to grind and see this
is one of those rare opportunities that
of course should not be wasted we should
take fully at full advantage of this
opportunity
by using it to transform our system of
government something we could never do
by any ordinary representative process
of government
if you'd like a copy of justice
markman's report and you're hearing
plaster all the time you can pick one up
on the way out if you're watching on our
live stream or listening on radio free
hillsdale 101.7 fm you can go to our
website at hillsdale.edu and find it
there also a recording of of this panel
will be on the college website within
the next 48 hours so you guys can
watch it again and again guys i think
we're going to go viral
join me in
thanking justice markman and professors
slack and postel and thank you all for
coming
you